my name is Alexander him I'm an
investigator here at Kamath
kwazulu-natal Research Institute for TB
and HIV so tell me about the project
you're working on to come up with better
ways to detect drug-resistant
tuberculosis this morning we were at the
hospital where there's tons of MDR and
XDR what's the problem that you're
trying to solve so we want to get people
on the best treatment as quickly as
possible and the problem is the tests we
have available at the moment
take two to three months and I'm not
very well well developed and so for two
or three months you have to treat
patients with drugs you don't know
whether they're gonna work or not you
may be treating them with five drugs
that work well you may be treating them
with five that don't as a result of this
patients can die or devel will develop
further resistance so we're trying to
we're trying to develop a rapid
comprehensive resistance test so that
patient can walk into the hospital we
can do the test and then within a week
or a few days we can give them the best
possible treatment what's your strategy
how are you going about development
something that doesn't exist and what
you have a lot of equipment here that
doesn't exist in many places in Africa
yeah what are you gonna do we're working
on the genetic code of drug resistance
so instead of growing the the bacteria
in the presence of drugs which takes a
long time we're trying to figure out the
barcode of resistance drug resistance
arises because of a mutation and then
you use sequencing equipment and you
come up with a barcode of resistance and
if we can figure out where the mutations
are and who has them we'll be able to
tell immediately who is resistant or not
one of the limitations of working on TVs
you have to work in a highly controlled
environment because TB is spread by
spreading the air so if I'm carrying a
culture with one of these potentially
deadly strains and I drop it on the
ground then I could affect you one of
the great things about K with is that we
have some of the best BSL threes in
South Africa if not in Africa
we're really focusing in an area where
we have xvr and the epidemics I'm
falling in front of their eyes and so
we're in a great position to take
something we've found in the lab and
tested immediately in the clinic we can
find a new mutation and we can figure
out and these strains resistance to this
drug and then I can go to King dinner
zoomer hospital or the Wednesday and say
hey look guys you shouldn't be you you
can use Caprio mice in in these patients
because we found out actually they're
susceptible or vice versa you shouldn't
be using this drug we could actually no
it's resist that we know these bugs are
resistant and so we can get that
feedback between lab and clinic which is
really what I think makes k with k with
unique we have some new drugs and we're
recycling some old drugs and I think in
the next two to three years we will be
able to dramatically shorten treatment
for drug resistance from 18 months to
two years what it is now down to we hope
nine months or six months now that will
really make a big impact on on treating
treating drug resistance you need this
new testing example exactly and
particularly as we introduce new drugs
we need to be able to rapidly monitor
someone's become resistant to them and
that's where I think this these new
genetic tools really be of benefit as
well
you